here's my wish can you make it what's
that it's valerian stew
I always knew you were just another rich
girl hi everyone its charlie we're
getting ready for Game of Thrones season
8 episode 2 I got a lot of questions
after episode 1 about Arya Starks
special weapon that she's having Gendry
make for her so I'll explain what it's
for
why she's using this instead of just
using her regular weapons she's already
got the Valyrian daggers they have all
the dragonglass in the world that she
could want why would she need a new
weapon there's actually a really special
reason for that what's going on between
the two of them in terms of their
relationship now that they're back
together and what's going on with Gendry
in terms of endgame because he does have
a claim to the Iron Throne through
Robert Baratheon so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Game of Thrones videos obviously
episode 2 is happening tonight I'll do a
separate video for that once it airs
we're still doing the HBO now giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video obviously careful for spoilers
from everything that happened during
episode 1 but you look at the diagram
Arya Stark drew for Gendry it's not just
a schematic it also tells you about the
special mechanical properties that the
weapon has it's a multi-function weapon
designed to suit her combat style
so within the world of Game of Thrones
Arya Stark knows what her limitations
are what her abilities are her assassin
life skills her small stature so she's
very shrewdly designing a weapon to
maximize her effectiveness during this
big Battle of Winterfell that we're
getting ready for you look at her she's
tiny compared to the whites in White
Walkers but as we saw from her fight
with Brienne of Tarth during season 7
episode 4 she can still hold her own
under a lot of circumstances even if
Brienne wasn't really going a hundred
percent against her the whole time as
cool as that fight was you have to think
about this from Brienne's perspective
she's used to training people like pod
and she looks at Arya like she's the
daughter of the person that she swore to
serve so what's that like Brienne is
gonna try to kill the sister of her lady
Sansa she's sworn to protect but from a
practical standpoint the show has a
problem to solve with her character so
they want to give everybody amazing
scenes during season 8 if Arya has been
training this whole time to become one
of the greatest assassins in the world
they want to write scenes for her fight
scenes in particular that will
help show that off so one they want Aria
to participate in the Battle of
Winterfell in a really big way to have
really cool fight scenes that showcase
those specific assassin like fighting
skills and three let her take advantage
of the really cool Valyrian dagger that
she now has in the new cool dragon glass
weapons that Gendry is custom making for
everyone and give her really cool
reunion moments with him so even though
needle is a very special weapon to her
and she has stuck a few pigs with it
under the current circumstances her pig
sticker isn't gonna be that useful
trying to stick white Walker pigs
thus the show had Arya come up with an
idea for a new weapon to use that would
allow her to do all these really cool
things without having to switch weapons
mid fight like she did with Brienne so
like say she's in the middle of the
Battle of Winterfell she wouldn't have
to drop a dragonglass weapon just so she
could use the Valyrian dagger and the
dagger itself is also limited in the way
you use it too because you can either
throw it at someone but then you
obviously have to run to go grab it out
of whatever white Walker or white you
threw it out and to if you're not
throwing it at them you have to get
really close within range of their arms
and it's just really easy to get dog
pilot under those circumstances
especially if you're as small as someone
like Arya that is why you look at this
weapon here and it lets you know that
she's gonna be going full Darth Maul
double bladed lightsaber during the
Battle of Winterfell look at the weapon
schematic it starts as this a long pull
arm one and clearly marked as
dragonglass the other end I wasn't so
sure about the first time I watched the
episode but I do believe they're trying
to say that both ends are tipped with
dragonglass
it was a brief period where I thought
she might have kendry refashioned the
Valyrian dagger and just use it for one
of the ends of the spear but now it
seems like she's using it as her backup
option so that she still doesn't have to
get up really close to White Walkers
when she's fighting but you can use the
polarity and dagger is a measure of last
resort maybe it's been a little while
maybe you remember it perfectly but that
Darth Maul fight where he's fighting
with his double bladed lightsaber and
then breaks it apart to dual wield you
have a pretty good idea for how Arya is
probably gonna be using this weapon
because it's designed so that she can
detach one end from the other and dual
wield with it you think back to Episode
one now and all those reunion scenes
that's probably why that has a special
Valyrian sword moment during her reunion
scene with Jon Snow in the godswood he's
all excited to show her his brand new
Valyrian steel sword Longclaw look at
this it's a Valyrian steel
or could you believe anything is so cool
she smiles and talks about how cool it
is not telling him about the Valyrian
steel dagger for some reason but Arya
says very specifically it's too heavy
for me talking about a traditional sword
and at the time it didn't seem like that
big of a deal but now we know they were
just for shadowing her designing a
really lightweight weapon that will
allow her to use her really cool skills
but also use her Valyrian dagger if she
really needed to there's also a very
practical reason from a battle
standpoint for having it start out as a
long pull arm because she could just do
a wield the whole time the long tip to
end nature of the pole arm weapon when
both ends are attached like you see here
during the season eight trailers when
she's twirling it around using it up on
the battlements is that she can use its
length to avoid having to get within
range of being touched by the whites in
White Walkers
so she avoids being dog piled
immediately because it's pretty clear
that they make it over the walls of
Winterfell but because both ends are
tipped even when the weapon is still in
pole form she can twirl it around like
this in attack White's behind her and in
front of her without having to swing the
weapon around each time it's much more
efficient Gendry chuckled a little bit
when she was explaining it because he
was still being playful he doesn't
understand the faceless man re up at all
he's still thinking of her the last time
that they were together that was why he
was referencing all those lines of
dialogue from season 3 milady and he
started calling her a rich [ __ ] just
joking a little bit so part of the fun
of their scenes together this season
early on especially is watching him
slowly get up to speed and realize
what's really going on with her but if
you're a big fan of those characters
together it seems pretty clear from
Arya's reactions to everything that
Gendry is saying during episode 1 she
still cares about him a lot it's just
the show has so much work to do during
episode 1 getting through all those
reunions as efficiently as possible
without losing any of the dramatic
payoffs you've been waiting for for the
past few years all these characters have
been apart and I mean all the characters
not just Gendry and Arya like they
wanted it to feel like really meaningful
moments with the characters so that's
why the fun of episode 1 was largely the
reunion moments with a couple really big
payoffs like Jon Snow R + L equals J
it'll be fun to see how their
relationship changes as they both get to
know each other a little bit better and
all the changes they've gone through
because even though Maisie Williams is
still adorable and kind of looks like a
child Arya is about 17 during the events
of season 8 which
remember is older than Sansa was when
she was forced to marry Tyrion and then
later Ramsay Bolton so within the world
of A Song of Ice and Fire Aria is viewed
as being an adult it's just that because
Maisie Williams has that baby face you
still think of tiny cute Aria when you
look at her like she was during season
one they even had a joke about that
during her reunion with Jon Snow how did
you sneak up on me you're so creepy and
calm now kind of like bran then she says
you used to be taller so if you're
thinking about endgame for aria Gendry
characters under there's lots of
questions about what will happen to them
because technically gantry does have a
claim on the Iron Throne depending on
what you think happens to the other
characters like John and Daenerys back
when Arya was still training at the
house of black and white then made her
way back home just based on the way the
faceless men work in the books
George R Martin made it seem like there
would be consequences for Arya using her
skills for her own selfish reasons
you're not allowed to go stealing faces
from anyone that you want that's why
Jack and hog are blinded her after she
bailed on her contract to kill the
merchants and instead killed Meryn Trant
as revenge for the supposed death of
Syrio Forel we should say he allegedly
died even though we never saw it on
screen so if you believe that the show
has abandoned any of the ideas that
there are rules about stealing faces and
naming names for you to kill yourself
Allah Arya's list then it's totally
possible for Aria and Gendry to end up
together if they both survive past the
finale there's still a lot of people
asking about Gendry being a Baratheon
and thus another candidate for the Iron
Throne but I don't think it's gonna come
to that and even if it did nothing about
what Gendry has done the past season
since he's come back has made it seem
like he would go against Jon Snow and
Daenerys both of whom have stronger
claims as they are legitimate heirs and
Gendry is still technically a bastard so
fun fact Game of Thrones genealogy in
history Gendry has a little Targaryen
blood in him through Robert Baratheon's
grandmother whose name was raela
Targaryen she was sister of Joe Harris
the second so you could make a joke the
Gendry is also a secret Targaryen on
Game of Thrones like you're not a real
character on Game of Thrones unless
you're secretly somebody else a little
history on Robert's rebellion as well
part of the reason why the realm was so
ready to accept Robert Baratheon as
their new king was because they accepted
that he had an ancient claim on the Iron
Throne via his Targaryen blood
that's how used to Targaryen rule
the realm had become he's different but
he's a change of pace from the Mad King
and that he's not trying to burn us all
alive but he's also kind of the same in
a way because he's still a little bit
Targaryen so think about it this way
should Jon Snow and Daenerys both
survive the war for the dawn in the war
with Cersei this season it's most likely
that they'll get married as Varys Davos
and Tyrion all suggested during episode
one accept rulership of Westeros
they can then legitimize Gendry so that
he can use the Baratheon name and they
can give him storms end which I believe
as of right now is not currently
occupied by any Lords we all know that
bran still wants his castle that's the
whole reason why he's turning tail on
Jaime and Tyrion because he thinks
Cersei is gonna give him what he's
wanted this whole time but there are so
many empty castles in Westeros right now
Highgarden is still empty
unless Samwell goes home horn Hill would
be empty dragons don't technically empty
unless Daenerys goes back although
usually when Targaryens sit on the Iron
Throne usually one of their brothers or
sisters occupies dragons so that's why
they have the title Prince of
Dragonstone like Rhaegar Targaryen was
Prince of Dragonstone in the way that
Prince Charles was Prince of Wales for
most of his life the last hearth has
just been freshly emptied the karhold
probably gonna get emptied pretty soon
to Deepwood Motte is definitely going to
be emptied shortly thank you very much
house Glover for not answering the call
so there's plenty of castles to go
around in the round for anyone who
survives the war for the dawn so let me
know in the comments though what do you
actually think is gonna happen with
Gendry and Arya at the end of the season
because there was that very special
scene that she had with Ned Stark during
season one where he said you're going to
be a lady in a castle someday wife to a
lord and she says That's not me
they also paid that off when she had the
reunion with Nymeria during season seven
where she said that's not you
so just because Gendry has come back and
she's still a little bit in love with
him doesn't mean that she's ready to
become a lady in a castle like Sansa is
the lady of Winterfell she still doesn't
want to be like Sansa so don't be
surprised if they swerve on some sort of
alternate happy ending for Gendry and
Arya and then there's the Ramsay Bolton
theory of Game of Thrones if you think
this is gonna be a happy ending you
haven't been paying attention
so just be prepared for a big twist on
the ending to their story but what will
happen is is my episode 2 video will
post tonight after the
err so look out for that in aa name a
new giveaway winner when I post the
episode 3 trailer video Monday morning
while you wait for everything click here
for my Game of Thrones season 8 episode
2 trailer video and click here for my
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you